it's only been a few days since armored
Coral six's reveal at the game awards
but we already have a ton of new
information about the game thanks to an
interview with from software's hidataka
Miyazaki at IGN the core of the game see
what I did there we'll be focused on
single player which is a departure from
previous entries in the series that
heavily featured multiplayer although
multiplayer will be a part of the game
the highlight of the game will also be
its boss battles again to every other
from software title of the last decade
the core I did it again gameplay however
will be decidedly not like other recent
from software Games quote no we've not
been making a conscious effort to try to
direct it more towards more Soul spawn
type gameplay first of all let me just
make that clear Miyazaki says in the
interview Miyazaki then enforces how
important customizing the max is going
to be stating that you will be able to
change out individual parts and that the
system will be way more involved and
detail failed than simply swapping out
armor sets like in Dark Souls or Elden
ring the key to winning he States will
be fine-tuning your Mech for whatever
task at hand the last major tidbits of
the interview are that the game will be
Mission focused rather than an open
world a la Elden ring and that from a
story perspective this entry will act as
a reboot for the franchise with quote no
direct links to the previous games in
terms of Continuing Story armored Core 6
wasn't the only announcement at this
year's game awards we also learned that
PlayStation Studios and house marks
returnal would also be coming to PC
before the end of the year if you
planned on picking the game up however
you're going to need to check those PC
specs because it's Ram requirements are
head scratching typically a modern game
on PC will have requirements of a
minimum of 8 gigs and a recommended 16
gigabytes to play on more optimal
settings returnal's PC ports doubles
those numbers with a minimum of 16
gigabytes in order to run the the game
and a recommended 32 gigabytes for high
quality settings while 32 gigabytes
isn't a wild amount of ram many recent
high-end PCS house 64 gigabytes or more
plenty of people purchase or build PCS
with only 16 gigabytes especially if the
rig is a little older and most gaming
laptops still hedge to 16 gigabytes with
only the most expensive offering
upgrades to 32 gigabytes or more in
short it seems you're going to need a
pretty beefy rig if you want to play the
game at higher resolutions or frame
rates so no switch port for returnal
anytime soon it seems a game that does
run on the switch is fortnite which is
adding YouTube's most popular content
creator Mr Beast to the game via its
icons line of skins the guy will be
bringing the giveaway Antics that made
him so popular in the first place to the
Battle Royale during a limited time
collaboration players will be able to
complete Mr BEAST's Extreme Survival
Challenge on December 17th the player
with the highest score will be declared
the winner and earn one million dollars
it real money by the way those eligible
and able to participate in the event
will have to collect coins and survive
in quote extreme challenges to get the
highest score possible they'll be able
to play this mode as much as they'd like
if they're not happy with their final
score to help increase their chances of
winning for the tournament goes live on
December 17th players will be able to
load into the island on December 13th to
practice for the upcoming event are you
excited for armored Core sex are you
going to participate in Mr BEAST's
extreme fortnite event let us know in
the comments and we'll see you next time
here for more Gamespot news you won't
see me though because I'm gonna go win
that million dollars